alex wood has returned home after a lost
season in a lost city in cincinnati last
year injury problems 1-1 to rough r-u-f
darren rough now the pitch
swing and that one is punched definitely
a base head into right field racing
around third is slater heading home and
he will score without a throw
one to nothing giants webb to bellinger
with a 1-1 and it's tap solely along
first
the pueblo pick it up and couldn't
squeeze it so bellinger's aboard
base hit 1-0 on turners off to a good
start three hits three runs batted in
over the first two games
lifts a fly ball the other way that
sends davis back at the track turns and
watches it hit off the wall get a chance
to see some of bellinger's speed he's
headed for the plate and will score to
tie the game at one justin turner with
an rbi double
[Applause]
it's his bottle out of the left sends
slater back twisting around and making
the catch to save a run
heck of a play by austin slater to take
an rbi away from corey
this is mike usremski to lead off the
inning for the giants there's a swing
yes it's a
ground ball right through the wide open
left side of the infield base hit right
along the left field line he's going to
try and stretch it into a double the
ball is fielded right along the sidewall
by the left fielder peterson the throw
to second is too late a double for mike
yasremski wood home with another payoff
and he walked him below tomok
to the third alex
woodward he's right
when alex what is right he doesn't walk
many guys
he's successful his walks are down and
three walks already and one in the two
yeah one and two thirds inning that's
that's not a good sign for alex wood or
the dodgers the giants have the bases
loaded and donovan solano coming up now
the ball in the dirt it bounces by
barnes and goes to the backstop
coming in to score is just and the other
runners move up as well the giants have
gone ahead two to one a gift
or as you ground it out back in the
first inning darren ruff on deck 2-2
floor as it's a high drive deep left
center field going back on the ball as
jack peterson at the wall looks up and
it is gone
wilmer flores with his first giants home
run it's three to one giants
turner serves one to right davis coming
on we'll watch it bounce inside the
chalk and trickle to the sidewall
turner's head to the second with his
second double
seeger waiting and swings and he kind of
muscles one out toward
second base flores playing out in
shallow right field
on a knuckle ball kind of liner lunges
back to his right makes a catch stands
up justin turner thought no way he's
going to catch that turner's over at
third flores flips to second duvan on
the bag and it's a double play
that was bizarre
and now the 3-1 pitch there's a high
drive into left center field and
bellinger's going back it's off the
bottom of the wall bellinger will pick
it up davis scores
and coming around and scoring as well as
heinemann and solano clears the bases
with a double
five to one giants talking about some of
the base running issues for the dodgers
take a look over the last couple innings
of how they've run themselves out of
some opportunities this game could be a
lot different
justin turner on second seeker hits a
knuckle ball
thinks it's gonna fall gets doubled up
ends the inning
next guy chris taylor led off with a hit
he's on first
sees the ball pop away
more bad base running the pitcher's in
the right spot he's out and then jack
peterson thinks this ball off
hernandez's bat's going to fall gets too
far off istremski catches it easily and
then
doubles up peterson just three outs too
many easy outs given away here's his 1-1
to bets
he pulls the liner to short caught there
throwback to first and another double
play
so another out on the bases for the
dodgers as barnes gets doubled off and
after five all giants so far this
afternoon
and he's run the table against him now a
drive deep into left field going back is
slater he stumbles and makes the catch
as he's falling over and bangs into the
lower edge of the wall out there
he's he's sitting up
and the center fielder yostremski over
to see if he's okay
well he was battling the wind and the
sun out there and he was also reaching
out with his right hand trying to figure
out where the fence was
now he
swings and it's a fly ball
shallow center field racing in his new
body makes a head first dive and makes
the catch
so mauricio dubon his first play in
center field this year not an easy play
watson deals 2-2
seeger pulls a line drive to right that
will get down for a base hit
justin turner headed for the plate
behind ballinger and the dodgers take
advantage of the two out air
to cut the deficit in half it's 5-3 here
he comes with a 2-2 taylor slaps it
right side the ball has eyes and a base
hit into right
seeger winds up at third and the dodgers
have the tying run aboard here in the
eighth inning
slow roller that finds its way through
dangerous dangerous matchup right here
for the giants
he gets hit and the bases are loaded
unraveling for the giants here in the
eighth
tigers at third his two-run single made
it 5-3 taylor's at second and peterson
aboard after he's hit by the first pitch
from rogers now hernandez who is the
star on opening night driving in five
a 1-2
off the end of the bat weakly to second
flores will throw high to first ruff
comes off of the bag to get it and tag
her hernandez
but an adventure of an inning for the
giants there they give up two honor and
runs
and a two-run game as we go to the ninth
in los angeles
lines one up the middle what a stab
and he throws him out
justin turner positioned directly up the
middle on one hop gets it
the third baseman is standing there and
just ho-hum throws you out easily and
you just want to go back in the dugout
and throw something break something
because your frustration you do
everything right and you're out the
dodgers down 5-3 ready to face trevor
gott in the ninth inning with 9-1-2
coming up smith hits one hard to left
center field yaz is over turns and
watches it go and it's a lead off home
run for will smith
so a 5-4 game the giants in out away
fly ball left field
the skrimski moves over he's got it and
the giants hang on to get their first
win under gabe kepler